i think it's cultural i think it's
absolutely cultural
there's this poll that goes around the
study where they ask young people what
do you want to be when you grow up
and you believe it or not some of these
kids well first of all in china
they said astronauts what do you want to
be when you're out as astronauts
when they ask these american kids and
kids in the uk what do you want to be
these poor kids
they wanted the stupidest job on the
planet youtuber
you know did you believe someone being
dumb enough to make a career out of
being on youtube that suck chris
man the canadian colonel i'm only half
kidding who's the astronaut
chris um the canadian colonel yeah he
was making youtube videos he's a
youtuber and an astronaut no i'm kidding
youtube's a legit job but i'm not being
an influencer is more so what they said
don't you see how what progress that
represents
though it to an extent but beautiful
what it needs to be is
influencer or youtuber comes second
right
so i'm i got on youtube because i
started as a journalist at
some of these companies i was doing
technology stuff i was building drones
then i started live streaming then i
started working for vice then fusion
from journalism i'm like this is an
excellent medium to bring
political commentary news and and
reporting
for you mention the astronaut he's an
astronaut first he's an influencer
second
so these kids shouldn't want to be
famous for the sake of being famous
they should strive to be something that
develops culture and builds on culture
but a lot of them just want to be famous
yeah i noticed this firsthand i
was a youtuber in 2006-7 and the reason
it was exciting to watch is because i
was also an actor in los angeles
and so the youtube was like a portal
into my main
life as soon as i stopped doing that and
didn't have a main life and all i was
doing was
relying on the videos it became much
less interesting
people stopped watching and it's only
when you're doing
i fully agree with what you're saying
being a internet youtube whatever this
is all supplement to what you're
really doing with your life and you can
allow people to see it and become a part
of
inspire people to do more as well so
that's why i'm really adamant about
making cultural stuff
so we we're going to be filming a vlog
with this bmx guy on sunday who people
mentioned the super chat hit me up and i
was like dude
yes we got a skate park here let's get
someone on a bmx to do some crazy cool
tricks
and we're going to start making more and
more stuff to inspire people
to do other stuff the youtube stuff is
fantastic because then people can see
what you're doing be inspired by it
so to wrap this all back up into a nice
little package
we've got people who are worried about
losing their jobs what we need is
people who are going to start their own
job instead of
getting a job from somebody else too
many young people and going back to what
i mentioned about young people saying i
can't find work make work
what did i say i did i went and played
guitar in the subway i didn't sit there
and say the government should give me
money actually i did receive
unemployment when i got fired
don't get me wrong i like that idea but
uh i said well i can't get a job
i can sit around and starve to death or
i can take my small little fiberglass
it's a strata acoustic fire i don't know
if they make them anymore and i was like
i'll go play some top 40s that i like
singing in the subway in chicago
unfortunately you need a permit to do it
so i had to go to i'd go to the
what was the thompson center camera
which the daily center
i go to the daily center fill out some
form and gave me this laminate that said
like okay this person is allowed to play
music in a subway
and then i would play uh like oasis and
ccr
and i was just having i was having fun i
would just put my my my gig bag out
and i would just start playing the
guitar and singing and having fun with
it because i like playing guitar and
singing
and i would make i would make like 15
bucks an hour and then i i
met someone who was like you know where
you make the real money
wrigley field go play outside of wrigley
oh you'll make money great you know how
much started making outside wiggly when
i was playing guitar 60 bucks an hour
100
yeah bucks an hour you know why you wait
until the game is over
you start playing some top 40s and these
drunk guys come out
and they're like they're all singing
with each other and like rocking back
and forth and they're just showering you
with money all drunk and happy and i'm
like
this is great i found my own work
you know now ultimately it wasn't enough
to
like it's it's not so easy to play eight
hours a day and
it's not necessarily marketable but for
a young guy in my 20s i didn't sit
around saying
someone should give me money or why
won't someone hire me i said i'm going
to find a way to make money
and so part of my philosophy has always
been the simplest way to think about
economics and jobs and resources is
there's ian he's sitting across from me
he's holding a green piece of paper
i need to convince him to give me that
green piece of paper without violence
without threats
following basic laws and rules be
persuasive
provide something of value to ian so hey
man
i made this you know this little doll of
you would you like to buy it
yeah and says here i'll give you my
green paper oh that's all you're really
doing you've got a universal trade
medium
can you convince someone to exchange
that with you for something you can
offer
you make me think about the rent thing
because i when i was in la new york
and chicago i was so stressed all
every month every month i worked as a
waiter i made 700 bucks a week i was so
stressed every month to pay my rent it
was like the last week of
every month i was just like like this
gut this
pain in my gut can i afford my bills
this month
and it was distracting it was taking up
my glucose it was wasting my time and my
energy
and eventually i decided i'm going to
live in my car
and i had no shower i would wash my
hands with rain water but
the stress was gone i had that for the
first time in my life i didn't worry
about can i survive this month
and also i was brainwashed like if i
can't pay my rent my life is over but i
would have lost access to my
my house and my my shower
that stress is insane this is crazy it's
crazy to me that you know
our our great grandparents our great
great grandparents the struggles they
went through to have a family
the the things they did not have no
guarantees just
hardship and today it's it's harder than
it was
maybe today it's harder than it was you
know 20 15 or so years ago we had this
great economic boom under
clinton i was a little kid so i don't
really know a whole lot about how that
went for most people but i've heard
about it
you know on tv and uh i guess then you
get the the
the 2008 crisis now you get the pandemic
crisis and the lockdowns
and people are all of a sudden having
their you know their chairs pulled out
from behind them and they're hitting the
ground
it's a shock to a lot of people mm-hmm
why
did getting back to ian rent was this
constant
source of of angst and i think that's
true for a lot of americans
but think about i'm not saying your
apartment in l.a was a palace
but my guess is relative to most parts
of history
it was a palace in terms of the
amenities and so one way to look at it
is yeah we're worried about
rent on spaces that in the past people
would say are you kidding me
uh you are living in a way that
rockefellers realistically could not
live let's not forget that the first
air conditioner was created for a
minneapolis
air in the 1930s these were window units
massive not even window units weren't
even ready these cost anywhere from 10
to 15
50 000 in the 1930s
now if you see a window unit it's in
poor parts of town
again what the rich enjoy is always an
everywhere preview of what everyone will
enjoy
in the freedom so not by not by 1930s
dollars though right you're talking
about today's dollars
oh no no 1930s dollars if you wanted to
but it was a ten
thousand dollar to 50. that's like the
equivalent of like millions precisely
that's why it was a minneapolis
heir wow who was buying the first
air conditioner and air to a fortune
yeah yeah could you imagine so like
you're this rich guy and you're like
check this out
it's 69 degrees in my penthouse people
be like
wow so i don't gotta you know i can rip
off all my sweat rags
it'd be like if we walked in and they're
like all your all it's all wireless
power in here there are no wires
everyone can charge everything
your phone is charging as soon as you
walk in the room amazing that that's
like
like man that's crazy i would pay a
couple million yeah
to be the first especially if you're a
youtuber you can show the world you know
you know there's a statue to the guy who
invented air conditioning in miami
oh is that so carrier is the most is it
willis carrier that's
yeah i i got to be honest it should be
because it built the south
i i got to be honest it is it's it's
people told me this and i'm pretty sure
it's true but
i've heard when i when i heard that
because i lived in miami for a little
bit
i was like get out of here i don't
believe you and they're like the the
stat is a statue the guy invented air
conditioning because
you could not live here without air
conditioning people don't get there
now it's remarkable
every building everywhere you go in
miami you can see
all of the condensation on the windows
because everyone's inside in the summer
or they're at the beach miami beach is
pretty awesome but they're inside for
the most part with the air conditioning
on blast
you know how they say think about what
that means because in india right now
1 percent and that's a high number of
new delhi is air conditioned
families are physically ill because it's
so
hot and they don't and you don't sleep
and so think about what it means that so
much of america is air-conditioned well
to to be fair london isn't very
air-conditioned either europe no
i don't know what their deal is we hate
going there don't get that hot
in america we have air conditioning
that's right we are
we're a different people a lot of people
use kerosene as well in like african
countries and things to uh you for light
because they don't have electric
light well they got gravity lights now
yes yes i bought one of those i love
those those are cool we should get one
we should
get in here okay here i see a gravity
light no it's a a
high ratio gear system and you lift a
rock up on
a on a rope or string and then over time
the rock's weight
pulls the the gears which spins powering
the light oh cool
and then once it goes all the way to the
bottom you just ship right back up 60
bucks
yeah yeah super cool but kerosene will
kill people a lot of death
from kerosene inhalation so we're what i
wonder is are we
have we caused a population boom that is
untenable like the white-tailed deer
they say
you need to hunt white-tailed deer
because they'll eat so much they'll grow
out of control and then they'll destroy
the ecosystem like
if we have air conditioning and
unlimited water and food are we just
going to over produce and then become
eat ourselves to death is that like okay
thanos
is part of starvation part of keeping
the human population
level so what's the statistic if you
took the whole world's population right
now and jammed them all into texas
texas would look like san francisco if
you added oklahoma to it
it would be the equivalent of putting
four people per house
with a yard in the house we haven't come
close to scratching the surface of the
united states not not only that i mean
elon musk is trying to go to mars
yeah not that i think mars life is going
to be i don't think people are we're
going to have cities on mars maybe maybe
we will
but they'll be bio-domes essentially
they'll be enclosed and and you know
we'll have to
build inside structures to maintain the
the atmospheres and things like that
maybe but i think one thing people often
overlook is that technology
solves a lot of the problems of our day
so uh are you familiar with the great
poop crisis
the manure crisis of new york city no uh
i could be wrong about this so you guys
can fact check me i want to make sure
but i was reading about how the turn of
the century 1900
1800s 1900s in in new york they were
like the manure crisis will destroy new
york city
because the horses are pooping
everywhere and the population density is
so large
they were like we predicted in 30 years
there will be piles of manure on every
street corner and
and then the car got invented yeah and
then all of a sudden the horses were
gone
carbon emissions now the carbon
emissions are happening this is what
people say
we need to invent the next iteration of
transport that
solves for that problem well you got
tesla on the rise
it's not perfect because electricity
still generates
you know carbon in other areas but you
know hydrogen cells or maybe
some kind of solid-state battery
technology could certainly improve this
maybe
better uh maybe we we eventually
implement enough renewables in certain
areas
for charging certain vehicles we if we
we could offset
a lot of our carbon emissions with
renewables but
right now we don't have technology to
just end carbon you know fossil fuel
technology
one of the problems we have with the
left is they're saying get rid of all
fossil fuels out right right now
we can't do that but we can use nuclear
wind
solar geothermal tidal hydro dam stuff
for certain certain bits that we could
offset and then we still have fossil
fuels for the long-term stuff of the
winter so
you can reuse carbon emissions too
almost immediately coming out of the
smoke stack you can recapture it and
then they could turn it into graphene
yeah
you can condense it let's never forget
that oil existed on this earth for
obviously millennia and no one knew that
it had a capability
and so to ian's point about that
graphene
we haven't scratched the surface of
discovering the different
ways that the world around us can power
us can
cure cancer all sorts of things and so
technology is going to fix this and your
the idea that the gas powered car is the
frontier of transportation
ignores history let's not forget in the
19th century
whale oil was the fifth largest industry
in the united states
things so a dynamic economy like ours to
presume
that gasoline-powered cars are the
frontier no no no
we just have to overcome the
authoritarians these these these central
planners these command economists
these are the people saying we should
ban airplanes because it's bad for the
for the planet
could you imagine if we had all these
horses pooping everywhere and they're
like band travel don't let people have
horses because we're worried about what
the horse manure looked like in 30 years
we're like let us invent
let humans invent it's fascinating to me
that you know that you know that
that old quote from the head of the
patent office where he's like everything
that can be invented has been invented
in like 1899 or something you've heard
that before
it's insane we didn't even discover the
electromagnetic spectrum at that point
now it's like man if this guy even
understood the the the electromagnetic
spectrum
as well as petrochemicals meant plastics
didn't exist
all of a sudden now they used to shotgun
shells used to be big thick brass
cartridges
now it's just plastic they still use
brass a little bit but uh it's it's
plastics replace a lot of things
the funny thing now is they're all
screaming oh but plastics are destroying
the planet
well now couple things have happened
there's been developments in fungi and
bacteria that can
that can break down plastics and turn
into sugar and we've also seen natural
emergence
of bacteria that eats plastic why
because
evolution life finds away i think
there's a lot of pessimists who think
the world is going to blow up and just
like we're all going to die and we're
doomed
and these people scare me because the
the look it's one thing
in my opinion talk about the political
conflict with these people that's what
i'm scared of
i'm not scared of the apocalypse because
i think humans are smart
i think humans invent and every problem
we've seen over the past humans have
done a really good job of adapting to it
and developing technologies to avert
certain things
however the big problem is the lunatic
ideologue authoritarians
who don't want that and instead say we
must have my command
central planning or effectively if you
know fascism or communism
then they tell people what they can or
can't do and then what happens chernobyl
blows up i think at the elephant's foot
and people are dying and there's
radioactive carbon particles all up in
the air and everyone's freaking out
the command economists caused lots of
problems i heard a conspiracy theory
that the cia was involved with blowing
up chernobyl
i don't know i don't ever hear anything
about it they're not smart enough trust
me yeah
they're like there's no way that was an
accident i don't know thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you